Hey so I'm Michael B Jordan and I'm just
hanging out here at BuzzFeed answering
some fan questions and I was trying to
think of something I could do while I
was answering these questions and I say
you know what let's bring in the puppies
[Music]
good one
let me think blade top of my head the
training process increase who was pretty
intense I kind of knew what to expect
somebody went through the first time on
Creed one cardio swimming weight lifting
diet and I have not kept up with the
workouts you know right after I got
finished doing Creed 2 I shot this other
movie called just mercy playing a lawyer
and I dropped weight but I'm getting
back hey these are ones okay these are
breads you will learn okay Jordan wise
he's precious
you don't bite these I was in Philly so
cheesesteak huh was that cheese day
yes
it depends on what albums out I'm very
much so the person of you know whatever
album's going on I burn that one over
and over and over and over and over
again so I think when I was shooting
Creek - ah that's me that's me alright
so I think Nipsey Hussle victory lap had
just drops all this - a lot of Nipsey
Hussle
I don't know it's above my pay grade but
I love Marvel you know I love like I
love that character so yeah it'd be able
to kind of like team up with like what's
uh Chadwick and Marvel and and Ryan and
hey I'm gonna separate you - hey hey at
you calm down buddy good to be able to
kind of give back on setting work with
them again would be would be a lot of
fun but who knows it's tough because
everybody's been you know on their own
careers and you know making great films
and television shows and stuff like that
but I definitely catch up with their
work you know being able to see you
knowing Jesse Plemons on black mirror
and and be able to see couch and look
those - yeah look Don is then in rings
grab it and you see everybody kind of
grow over the years and you know how
careers it you know that that that took
off and become very successful is it's
exciting to kind of see them progress
cuz we all kind of came from that
frightened LA's family
I never wanted to be an actor growing up
there was something that kind of chose
me but over the years I think learning
the power of cinema
you know the storytelling can make
people think you know and feel and ask
questions yeah all of those reasons is
kind of why I fell in love with actually
over time and as we decided to you know
make it a career I don't know I've been
checking out a lot checking off a lot of
my boxes maybe like some type of like
Jason Bourne double-oh-seven give me a
gun in the suit cars ah international
blowing some stuff up but with heart and
character and story not just a you know
a cheesy film I want to do something
that makes you think it makes you feel
so a project around that any world anime
I think I'm gonna go with hey what's up
which one an epoch huh
i'ma say in the road see why because I
love you know Japanese culture I love to
kind of be able to play in that world
and mixture between old-school ninjas
and seals and and friendships and bonds
and all the things that they kind of put
into the roads through the show I think
that would be pretty cool
hey hey I seen the row through how I
want to stay in the row to these puppies
were provided by Pacific pups rescue
thank you big guy
so guys want a dog little phone